now at 40 in single Galloway is using a
sperm donor to get pregnant but when she
filtered the search for donors of her
own race the number of options went from
hundreds to a handful it literally felt
like you were on a hunt it almost felt
like I was having a bit of my decision
taken away from me Dr Tia Jackson Bay a
New York City fertility doctor says
every patient of color at her practice
has shared that struggle I thought
people were exaggerating and it turned
out that that's just not true according
to our analysis of the country's four
largest cryobanks less than four percent
of available sperm is black why are we
seeing such slow numbers when it comes
to racial donors you know historically
donors have been recruited from places
where maybe black men are not present
you know institutions of Higher Learning
certain areas Geographic areas in the
country